the Texas newspaper the Dallas Morning
News has endorsed Hillary Clinton for
president so who cares well this is the
first Democrat to be endorsed by the
dallas morning news since before world
war two it endorsed franklin delano
roosevelt in 1940 the Dallas Morning
News says that it really had no choice
but to throw its support behind Hillary
Clinton and this is not a liberal
newspaper this is a newspaper that in
its endorsement of Hillary Clinton still
said and made very clear were really
very skeptical of what it is that
Hillary Clinton would do were skeptical
of the Democratic Party and its platform
but and to quote unlike Donald Trump
Hillary Clinton has experience in actual
governance a record of service and a
willingness to delve into rear pop real
policy although they are very very
skeptical of the Democratic Party and
for an endorsement of one candidate over
another it's fascinating how even-handed
this Hillary Clinton endorsement is it
mentions they're concerned about
Hillary's email controversy but that
Donald Trump is just so unprepared right
so lacking in judgment that they simply
cannot endorse him this is the model for
how any reasonable Republicans should be
feeling truly if you're a reasonable
person even if you're politically
conservative whatever it is that that
means to you but you've got half a brain
in your skull this is how you should see
the race well Hillary Clinton maybe to
my left but Donald Trump is a systemic
danger to the future of not only the
United States but also the world he is
just too dangerous and in the end
remember Hillary Clinton is a moderate
Democrat she's not going to do anything
insane by historical presidential
standards now for many people
neoconservative war Hawking is insane
and that that's not exactly what I'm
getting at my point is that she will no
doubt operate within a completely
predictable spectrum sometimes were
critical of that we say you know the
spectrum is too narrow the spectrum of
valid debate and who can be a eight
national level politician
that spectrum is too narrow when we're
thinking of Hillary Clinton versus
Donald Trump Donald Trump is outside of
that that scope not in a way that we
should be happy about but in a way that
we should be very very scared about
voting for Donald Trump as as the Dallas
Morning News has said basically means
I'd rather the country risk destruction
and being an even bigger embarrassment
worldwide than it was under george w
bush which let me remind you was pretty
bad uh then to have someone I just kind
of dislike as president of the United
States in Hillary Clinton now the
implications in Texas are really pretty
minor Texas is unlikely to go for
Hillary Clinton we've talked about the
bigger longer term project of making
Texas blue not gonna happen this
election unless something that I can't
even imagine what happened at Trump is
ahead of Hillary Clinton roughly 50 to
40 in Texas eight percent for the
Libertarian candidate Gary Johnson there
on Nate Silver's fivethirtyeight.com has
Texas at a ninety one-point-three
percent probability of going to Donald
Trump on Election Day there's a funny
comment that I've seen time and again on
the Internet in response to the Dallas
Morning News endorsement which was
newspapers are clearly being taken over
by left-wing activists and and that's
why the Dallas Morning News has endorsed
Hillary Clinton but two thoughts on that
number one if the dallas morning news is
now liberal media it only proves that
this country is even more illiterate
when it comes to media literacy than
even I thought and let me tell you my my
outlook on that issue is pretty bleak
but number two let's also recall that an
endorsement of Hillary Clinton is not an
insanely left-wing endorsement because
we're talking about a very very moderate
Democrat here so how much does any
individual endorsement matter not very
much what can an endorsement from a
paper like the Dallas Morning News tell
us about this race in the dynamics
actually quite a bit